how's it goin rest - fair yeah and I
have some updates for your brows and
there's not goddamn cars outside
so tomorrow me and my said we're going
to Singapore I know it's pretty damn
crazy we're going to the star count
convention I don't know exactly what it
is but and we kind of jumped on it last
minute and that's why it's so sudden so
I will be gone for from Monday to Friday
I'm really sorry about I know I've been
away a lot lately and it really sucks I
hate to be it but um it might even be a
good thing because internet is not
working here at moment there's something
wrong without global speed it's taking
me 12 hours to upload a video instead of
I don't know in Sweden it took me 12
minutes so it's really frustrating that
I can do it but hopefully it will be
fixed once we come back and so I know
you bros are like oh we want more
dashing man and I can't do anything
about it so yeah I know I have a lot of
broads in Singapore so it's gonna be
cool meeting you I never been anywhere
in East of East of the world so it's fun
it's gonna be cool I'm excited for it I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun and I
have a few videos scheduled I think but
it's not gonna be a lot and I hope I can
get back with two or three videos a day
at least once I get back and I have
proper internet again so I'm really
sorry bro I really miss making videos
and I really there's a lot of stuff that
I want to do but I can't and it's no
it's it's frustrating me if you follow
me on Twitter
you'll see a lot of angry right
but anyway is the slowest truck ever
coming but anyway I just want to say
thank you both for being understanding
I'm always doing what I can and this is
all I got
anyway I do have 1,400 videos uploaded
so if you want you could just watch some
of some playlists while I'm gone you
know it'll be great I'll leave a link to
that in the description other than that
you have a pretty face
keep being pretty beautiful and I'll see
you on Friday hopefully Salzburg love
you